dafür geht es jetzt weiter mit dem
nächsten Tagesordnungspunkt der die
Nummer 24 in dieser Sitzungswoche es
geht um Ehrenamt und Engagement wir
haben heute morgen schon einen Weg von
ganz interessantes Interview dafür
zugeführt mit gelind aus der
SPD-Fraktion und Volker Ulrich aus der
Unionsfraktion es geht darum wie auch in
Zukunft
ehrenamtliches Engagement gefördert und
beibehalten werden kann Grundlage für
die Debatte jetzt hier im Parlament ist
ein Bericht der Bundesregierung der
vorherigen Bundesregierung muss man
sagen
ein Bericht der von einer unabhängigen
Kommission erstellt wurde eben Auftrag
des Bundesministeriums für Familie
Senioren Frauen und Jugend und danach
mit einer Stellungnahme der
Bundesregierung versehen jeder Bericht
das ist inzwischen der dritte übrigens
jeder Bericht beleuchtet besondere
Schwerpunkte des bürgerschaftlichen
Engagements im Fokus des dritten Bericht
steht junges Engagement im digitalen
Zeitalter und der erste Redner ist Sven
le parlamentarischer Staatssekretär im
Innenministerium zuhören rund 29
Millionen Menschen engagieren sich in
Deutschland jeden Tag ehrenamtlich 29
Millionen Menschen das ist eine
beeindruckende Zahl und all diese
Menschen sind Motor und sind Herz
unserer Demokratie ihr Engagement ist
der Kit der unsere Gesellschaft
zusammenhält und jeder und jedem
einzelnen von diesen 29 Millionen
Menschen möchte ich im Namen der
Bundesregierung aber sicher auch im
Namen des gesamten Hauses beim
aufrichtigen Dank aussprechen
all den all den Freiwilligen die
Hunderttausenden geflüchteten Menschen
aus der Ukraine die Ankunft in
Deutschland erleichtern all den
engagierten die in Sportvereinen in der
Freiwilligen Feuerwehr oder in
Kirchengemeinden jeden Tag für andere da
sind all denen die täglich Zusammenhalt
Leben erst recht in diesen
herausfordernden Zeiten der vorliegende
dritte engagementbericht ist einer von
insgesamt fünf berichten und das Thema
dieses Berichtes ist hoch aktuell junges
Engagement im digitalen Zeitalter drei
Ergebnisse sind dabei zentral erstens
die Digitalisierung eröffnet neue Wege
sich einzubringen und zu engagieren
zweitens digitale Plattformen werden
dabei immer wichtiger und drittens
digitales Engagement schafft auch mehr
Flexibilität zu nutzen etwa mehr als 40%
der Jugendlichen auch oder sogar
ausschließlich digitale Medien für ihr
Engagement der Bericht zeigt uns also
wichtige Trends auf und er gibt uns aber
auch auch einen ganzen Strauß an
Aufgaben mit wir sollen Menschen und
Vereine beim Einstieg in das digitale
Engagement besser unterstützen wir
sollen helfen nicht digitales und
digitales Engagement besser miteinander
zu verbinden und wir sollen das
Engagement von Jugendlichen stärker
würdigen
wir im Bundesfamilienministerium was ja
auch das engagementministerium ist
wollen den 29 Millionen engagierten den
Rücken stärken zum Beispiel zusammen mit
der Stiftung für Engagement und Ehrenamt
seit ihrer Gründung vor zwei Jahren hat
die Stiftung bereits mehr als 7000
Verein Organisationen mit rund 70
Millionen Euro unterstützt außerdem
arbeiten wir gerade einen neuen
engagementstrategie damit Engagement so
einfach wie möglich gemacht wird und
gerade in dieser Woche haben wir einen
weiteren Meilenstein erreicht die
Bundesregierung hat das erste Demokratie
fördergesetz auf den Weg gebracht
mit diesem Gesetz schaffen wir mehr
Planungssicherheit für diejenigen die
sich täglich für andere und für unsere
Werte einsetzen ihre wichtige Arbeit
stellen wir auf eine stabile und
nachhaltige Grundlage denn je mehr
Menschen sich gesellschaftlich
engagieren desto stärker ist der
Zusammenhalt in der Gesellschaft und
desto stärker ist die Wehrhaftigkeit
gegen die die unsere Demokratie
gefährden wollen Engagement zu fördern
ist also ein aktiver Beitrag Demokratie
und Zusammenhalt zu stärken deswegen
danke ich den Experten Experten für
diesen wertvollen Bericht und freue mich
jetzt sehr auf die Debatte dazu vielen
Dank
das Wort erhält Ralf Edelhäuser für die
cdu/csu-fraktion
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen der dritte
engagementbericht namens Zukunft
Zivilgesellschaft junges Engagement
digitalen Zeitalter ist für mich zu
allerersten Mal ein Grund ja für
freudigen Optimismus denn er zeigt dass
oftmals ja die Jugend irgendwie als
orientierungslos oder schwer zu
begeistern bezeichnet wird dass die
durchaus engagiert sind und auch ihr
Leben entsprechend meistern denn etwa
zwei Drittel etwa zwei Drittel der 14
bis 27-Jährigen geben an dass sie
gesellschaftlich einbringen und ich
finde diese Zahl wirklich beeindruckend
und deswegen glaube ich im ganzen Saal
hier werden Sie mir zustimmen einfach
mal Danke sagen an diese Jugendlichen
und junge Erwachsenen
und nicht erst seit der corona-zeit ist
es ehrenamtlich Engagement hat sich das
irgendwo geändert und verändert und
gerade auch bei den jungen Menschen es
ist digitale geworden und deswegen wirkt
sich das natürlich auch auf das Ehrenamt
aus es gibt neue Formate es gibt neue
Strukturen nun ist es aber so dass diese
aktive Mitgestaltung an der Gesellschaft
und auch an den relevanten Themen die
sich in unserer Zeit ergeben das ist ein
jungen Menschen das ein großes Anliegen
ist da müssen wir aber auch die
Rahmenbedingungen schaffen was die
Anforderungen der engagierten betrifft
und nicht dass ich die engagierten an
die Anforderungen irgendwie anpassen
müssen das glaube ich eine ganz wichtige
Geschichte und deswegen glaube ich auch
dass die Anpassung der Wahrnehmung
dieses Ehrenamtes ganz wichtige
Geschichte ist denn in den letzten
Jahren
hatten wir eigentlich nur das physische
Ehrenamt wir haben eine Vereinen in den
Verbänden in den Feuerwehren in den
Kirchen der hat sich alles abgespielt
aber jetzt hat sich das verlagert in die
digitale Welt für mich gehört aber ganz
klar beides zusammen das reale Ehrenamt
aber auch das digitale Ehrenamt und das
muss man auch entsprechend stärken die
Jugend von heute
die Jugend von heute will Verantwortung
übernehmen das will sie aber nicht mehr
in irgendwelchen festen Strukturen und
starren Strukturen mehrmals so in den
Verein war mit Satzungen
Satzungsänderungen mit Notar und so
weiter neben diesen Formalismus will die
junge Leute über die wollen Optionen
haben die wollen was ausprobieren und
das wollen sie auch im Ehrenamt und das
ist gut so und das finde ich richtig gut
weil das Projekt bezogen einfach immer
wichtiger wird und sie wollen Sie mit
unserer Gesellschaft auseinandersetzen
sie wollen sich da auch einbringen und
sie wollen aber auch nicht darauf
verzichten wir als Gesellschaft können
auch nicht darauf verzichten dass ich
die jungen Leute einbringen und dann
müssen wir als Parlament auch darauf
reagieren können
was ist dazu zu sagen was ist es was was
muss man gemacht werden die Definition
zum Beispiel vom gemeinnützigen Zweck in
der Abgabenordnung das muss geändert
werden das muss angepasst werden auf die
neuen Formate die wir hier auch in der
heutigen Zeit eben sehen wir brauchen
mehr Kompetenzzentren die bundesweit
beraten und entsprechend vernetzen um
Synergien zu schaffen aber auch um
irgendwelche Hemmschwellen dies noch
vielleicht im digitalen Engagement gibt
auch zur herabzusetzen und einfach zu
verringen und das sieht aber auch das
bestehende Vereine und Verbände die es
in der heutigen Zeit der schon seit
vielen vielen Jahren gibt es die die
sich auf diese Digitalisierung
eingelassen haben mich einfach mal den
Bayerischen Landessportverband oder
einfach Vereine die gerade auch bei der
corona-pandemie hier umgestellt haben
die haben ja quasi ein Quantensprung
gemacht hin nur vom Sportverein hier die
haben was online gemacht der Mann
Quantensprung gemacht und das glaube ich
ganz gut die haben das einfach auch
schon in der Realität vollzogen und
deswegen müssen wir alle zusammen diese
Bedingungen für die Wahrnehmung von
digitalen Ehrenamt und Engagement auch
stärken und schaffen und zwar im
ländlichen Raum wie auch in den Städten
und Gemeinden dazu brauchen wir stabiles
Datennetz dazu brauchen wir aber auch
ein ordentlichen Bildungsgrad egal auf
welche Schule das wir uns bewegen das
ist wichtig dass wir die Leute darauf
vorbereiten dass die Kompetenzen
schaffen und das ist dann auch für die
jungen Leuten in der Zukunft so
weitergeht und die haben viele
Einschränkungen in der Vergangenheit
gehabt da war dann aber auch dass das
Jugendzentrum die Jugendhäuser haben wir
neue Wege gesucht ihr auch Neues
ausprobiert und es auch umgestellt und
umgesetzt und das glaube ich ist der
ganze entscheidende Geschichte das ist
so geklappt hat und jetzt geht es darum
dass die Digitalisierung auch im
Ehrenamt breiteren Raum einnimmt das ist
überfällig wir können stolz sein dass
die Jugend das schon gemacht hat dass
sie da dabei ist dass sie sich einbringt
und dafür müssen wir sagen dass wir
diese jungen Leute nicht verlieren wir
brauchen jeden das müssen ausbauen egal
ob digital oder auch im Mittelalter
leben vielen herzlichen Dank schöne
Weihnachten
als nächstes erhält Ariane Fischer das
Wort für die SPD-Fraktion
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin Werte
Demokraten Liebe engagierte mit
Erlaubnis der Präsidentin zitiere
zitiere ich Regine Hildebrandt sag mir
nicht dass es nicht geht sag mir wird
das
das zivilgesellschaftliche Engagement in
Deutschland verändert sich mit dem Fokus
junges Engagement im digitalen Zeitalter
hat sich der dritte engagementbericht
befasst er zeigt auf dass Engagement im
Umbruch ist es wird in Teilen spontaner
agiler und digitaler auch in der
Vereinsarbeit durch die durch die
Digitalisierung entstehen neue Formen
des Engagements
basisdemokratische Bewegungen ohne feste
Struktur aber mit großer politischer
Kraft jedoch ohne Rechtsform damit
fallen Sie aus unseren förderkulissen
weitgehend heraus unsere
Förderinstrumente sind nämlich momentan
auf eine analoge Welt ausgerichtet
unsere Instrumente passen also ich
möchte sagen noch nicht zum realen und
künftigen Engagement übrigens nicht nur
von jungen Menschen
jetzt ist also die Frage wird in Zukunft
geht und wie die wie ein Kollege neulich
auf dem Podium desillusionieren wie ich
fand einwarf eher ändern Sie die Zehn
Gebote als die bundeshaushaltsordnung
wir stecken da wohl in einem Dilemma
rund 29 Millionen Menschen werden das
schon gehört engagieren sich
ehrenamtlich davon sind rund sechs
Millionen unter 30 Jahre alt ihr
Engagement anders jedenfalls teilweise
wir kommen wir aber zu einem einfachen
handhabbaren Instrumentenkoffer der
staatlichen Unterstützung der den
Bedarfen der engagierten auch dient die
Koalition steht im Staat Block um in
diesem Sinne bis Ende 2024 die
engagementstrategie des Bundes neu
aufzulegen
darin fordert der
unterausschussbürgerschaftliches
Engagement neben den Ministerien dem
engagementnetzwerk BBE und der
Bundesstiftung DCE eine gestaltende
Rolle ein denn wir Parlamentarier sind
in unseren Wahlkreisen an den realen
Bedarfen vor Ort nah dran die
Ehrenamtlichen sagen uns es zu
bürokratisch ist zu kompliziert viel
Aufwand es geht um Fragen von
förderperiodenversicherungen Haftungen
Gemeinnützigkeit oder Grundkosten für
Vereine finden sich weniger Vorstände
Menschen wollen sich kurzfristiger in
Projekten oder spontan in der
Katastrophenhilfe engagieren und
Engagements immer noch privilegiert weil
sich zum Beispiel ärmere Familien den
Freiwilligendienst des Kindes den Laptop
oder auch die Fahrzeug Jugendkonferenz
schlicht nicht leisten können
wir wollen deshalb das nicht nur
Verbände sondern engagierte und vor
allem noch nicht engagierte die
Strategie aktiv mitgestalten können in
dezentralen Veranstaltungsformaten und
auf der bereits freigeschalteten
Online-Plattformen an der alle mitmachen
können
die Zivilgesellschaft ist eine tragende
Säule der Demokratie und wird immer
stärker eine Zukunftsfrage für die
Stabilität von Staat und Gesellschaft
sein dort wird Demokratie positiv erlebt
als Gegengewicht zu Ohnmacht Hass und
wie wir kürzlich erst erlebt haben
umsturzfantasien
digitalaktive junge Menschen fühlen sich
politisch und gesellschaftlich wirksamer
gerade im ländlichen Raum wird auch das
digitale Engagement als Alternative
vielleicht fehlende reale
Beteiligungsmöglichkeiten erlebt
so wie wir die Demokratie
Entschuldigung wie wir die wehrhafte
Demokratie mit Demokratie fördergesetz
absichern müssen wir auch das
zivilgesellschaftliche Engagement in
Zukunft mit einem engagementfördergesetz
flankieren
wir liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen
können eine lebendige Partnerschaft
zwischen Staat Wirtschaft und
Zivilgesellschaft mit direkten
zukunftsweisend flexiblen und
unbürokratischen Instrumenten
ermöglichen die Bundes
engagementstrategie wird zeigen wie er
Diät in diesem Sinne frohe Weihnachten
und ein gesundes neues Jahr
nächste Rednerin ist für die
afd-fraktion gerrituy
[Applaus]
frau Präsidentin meine Damen und Herren
der dritte Engagement Bericht handelt
von engagierten Jugendlichen und im
Internet und Überraschung die Jugend
nutzt gerne das Internet und sie nutzt
das heutige gelegentlich auch für
Engagement ein neues Wort das das
frühere Ehrenamt einschließt und das ist
erweitert um spontanes und weitgehend
unorganisiertes Engagement Prototyp
dafür sind die Fridays for future Hüpfer
die sich bei der Ampel großer
Beliebtheit erfreuen dabei wird
unterstellt dass diese und ähnliche
Gruppen für einen guten Zweck eintreten
im Bericht wird dafür dass politisch
korrekte Wort ziviles Engagement genutzt
und falls es noch nicht wussten
es gibt auch unziviles Engagement der
Prototyp dafür wiederum ist die
querdenkerszene man spricht auch von
dunklem Engagement anders als die Hüpfer
gehören die Querdenker folglich auch
nicht zur Zivilgesellschaft sonst zur
sondern zur unzivilen Gesellschaft
diese Worte sind sicherlich sehr bewusst
gewählt denn die Linken argumentieren
seit Jahrzehnten das ist unsere Sprache
ist die unser Denken bestimmt und was
mit unanfängt ist eigentlich immer
schlecht aus unserer Sicht müssten wir
dann formulieren was die Ampel macht ist
und Politik zumindest ist sie und zivil
denn sie schadet ja mehrheitlich unseren
Bürgern
aber ganz offenbar zählt aus ampelsicht
längst nicht mehr jeder Bürger zur
Zivilgesellschaft das mutet wirklich
schon Orwells an
so also die Jugend nutzt gerne das
Internet für gesellschaftliches
Engagement sie zeichnet auch schnell mal
einen Shitstorm der dann schnell auch
unziviert werden kann es soll natürlich
nur das zivile Jugendliche Engagement
und unterstützt und gefördert werden
dafür steht bereits eine Stiftung bereit
die jährlich 30 Millionen Euro vergeben
kann meine Damen und Herren wir alle
wissen dass die Tugend der Politik nicht
der Anstand ist sondern die
Angepasstheit wollen wir die jetzt
wirklich auch ins Ehrenamt tragen es
liegt nur ein verdammt schmaler Grad
dazwischen ehrenamtliche uneigene sich
in ihrem Tun zu unterstützen oder sie
samt Ehrenamt zu kapern und für
staatszwecke zu missbrauchen
indem man sie anfüttert und auf diese
Weise allmählich abhängig macht vom
Staat und dann vielleicht die
Anforderungen für die Unterstützung
hochschreibt vielleicht müssen unsere
jungen engagierten dann erstmal unser
neues Glaubensbekenntnis ablegen ich
glaube an den menschengemachten
Klimawandel oder ich gelobe mit allen
meiner Kraft künftig gegen Rechts zu
kämpfen können sich nicht vorstellen
dann haben sie sich noch nicht mit dem
neuen Demokratie fördergesetz
beschäftigt mit diesem Instrument soll
zukünftig sogar nachhaltig also
dauerhaft belohnt werden was gegen
Rechts ist
die in ampelkreisen geschätzte
Aktivistin annetta Khane schreibt bei
der Bundeszentrale für politische
Bildung ich zitiere einer der Gründe für
das dunkelste Kapitel der deutschen
Geschichte und ihrer verheerenden Folgen
der Siegeszug des Nationalsozialismus
und damit für Krieg und Holocaust war
ohne Zweifel die Schwäche der
Zivilgesellschaft der deutschen
Zivilgesellschaft das zivile unterlag
die Gesellschaft mit samt ihren Eliten
wandte sich dem Nationalsozialismus zu
und wurde zum Teil seines Systems Zitat
Ende wurde zum Teil des Staat in Systems
meine Damen und Herren das war nicht nur
damals verheerend das ist immer
gefährlich deswegen brauchen wir auch
keine angepachte Zivilgesellschaft
sondern genau das Gegenteil eine
wehrhafte Zivilgesellschaft die sich
nicht staatlich vereinnahmen lässt eine
Gesellschaft die die Bürger nicht einmal
mehr spaltet in Zivil und zivilen eine
wirklich inklusive Bürgergesellschaft
also danke
[Applaus]
für die FDP-Fraktion erhält das Wort
Martin Gassner Herz
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin meine
Damen und Herren schade dass wir so eine
Rede zu diesem tollen Thema gerade eben
hören mussten
für uns Freie Demokraten sind die
Teilhabe an der Gesellschaft deren
Mitgestaltung und ihr Zusammenhalt
Ausdruck Stürzer irgendetwas
Bürgerlichkeit sie gehören zu einer
selbstbestimmten und freien
Zivilgesellschaft und sind entscheidend
für unsere Lebensqualität das Engagement
ist so vielfältig wie die Themen die
unsere Gesellschaft prägen von Sport
soziales und Kultur bis hin zu Umwelt
Gesundheit und Sicherheit in der
blaulichtfamilie und vieles vieles mehr
mit Blick auf die Zukunft der
Zivilgesellschaft sind Mitwirkungen und
Einbindung gerade junger Menschen
besonders wichtig dazu gehört
insbesondere wie dies auch aus dem
Bericht hervorgeht das Potenzial von
digitalen Lösungen zur Stärkung des
Ehrenamts auszuschöpfen dieses Potenzial
wurde durch die vorherigen
Bundesregierung fast kaum unterstützt
ein Beispiel hierfür ist das Fehlen eine
Anwendungssoftware für die erleichterte
steuereinführung für
zivilgesellschaftliche Organisationen
genau da wollen wir anpacken und für
Lösungen sorgen die Bundesregierung hat
eine digitalstrategie entwickelt Teil
dieses Strategie ist die vernetzte
Gesellschaft so soll unter anderem bis
2025 in Deutschland die
Zivilgesellschaft durch die Initiative
gestärkt und neue ki-projekte
angeschoben werden außerdem so ein
Beratungs- und Informationszentren für
KI wie das zvki ausgebaut und neue
geschaffen werden darüber hinaus planen
wir durch das Bundesprogramm Demokratie
leben jene Initiativen und Akteure zu
stärken die digitale Kompetenzen und an
Engagement gegen Hass im Netz fördern
aber auch mit der National
engagementstrategie die heute schon
öfters angesprochen wurde die aktuell
von uns gemeinsam mit der
Zivilgesellschaft erarbeitet wird so
dass Ehrenamt von seinen Fesseln gelöst
werden
eine gute Nachricht ist auch das haben
wir heute schon mehrfach gehört
dass es sich aus dem Bericht ableiten
lässt dass junges Engagement hoch ist
und da ist und viel mitwirkt
insbesondere Menschen erfinden
zahlreiche neue digitale Formate wodurch
ein neues engagementfeld entsteht
allerdings profitieren engagierte von
diesen Vorteilen nur dann wenn Sie auch
die Möglichkeit haben es tatsächlich in
Anspruch zu nehmen besonders
Bewohnerinnen und Bewohner von
ländlichen Regionen werden immer noch
von den Vorteilen des digitalen Wandels
wegen schleppenden Netzausbau in
Deutschland ausgeschlossen
genau deshalb legen wir beispielsweise
auf die breitbandfinanzierung noch was
oben drauf wir werden so 2023 beinauts
dreifache ausreichenden Vergleich zu dem
was 2021 noch gelungen ist meine Damen
und Herren Ehrenamt bedeutet dass
Menschen aus freien Stücken und Liebe
zum Nächsten füreinander da sind und
gemeinsam Berge versetzen ich finde ein
weihnachtliches Thema kann es eigentlich
nicht geben
in diesem Sinne wünsche ich Ihnen
besinnliche Festtage und einen
erholsamen Jahresausklang im Kreise
Ihrer Liebsten vielen Dank
auch Martin Gessner Herz vergisst nicht
hier dem Abgeordneten und ihren Familien
frohe Weihnachtstage zu wünschen und
einen guten Rutsch aber soweit sind die
Abgeordneten noch gar nicht stehen noch
einige Tagesordnungspunkte an bis heute
Mittag ca 15 Uhr auch wenn es heute
relativ geschmeidig voran geht also gar
keine Verzögerung bislang im Ablauf
hören wir aber erstmal Türkei aus der
Linksfraktion 2020 offiziell den
Familienministerium vorgelegt wurde erst
drei Jahre später findet die Debatte im
Bundestag dazu statt das verdeutlicht
die mangelnde Wertschätzung der
Bundesregierung gegenüber den rund 29
Millionen ehrenamtlich engagierten
Menschen in unserer Gesellschaft
den Menschen die sich tagtäglich neben
Beruf Familie und anderen
Verpflichtungen in vielen Bereichen
ehrenamtlich engagieren gilt mein großer
Dank
vielen Dank auch an die
Sachverständigenkommission die diesen
Bericht verfasst hat ohne das
bürgerschaftliche Engagement würde so
einiges in Deutschland nicht mehr laufen
beispielsweise die ehrenamtliche
Flüchtlingshilfe ohne sie hätte der
Staat bei der Aufnahme von ukrainischen
Kriegsflüchtlingen voll versagt
Defizite in der Erfüllung der
öffentlichen Aufgaben sollten aber nicht
dauerhaft durch das Ehrenamt und
Freiwilligendienste kompensiert werden
im dritten engagementbericht geht es um
die Zukunft der Zivilgesellschaften
nämlich jungges Engagement im digitalen
Zeitalter über 43 Prozent der Befragten
jungen jungen engagierten beschreiben
sich als digital engagierte dadurch
verändern sich die Rahmenbedingungen des
Ehrenamts besonders das Thema soziale
Ungerechtigkeit im digitalen Engagement
von Jugendlichen sollte uns allen zu
denken geben
laut dem Bericht sind 47 Prozent der
HauptschülerInnen deutlich
seltener gesellschaftlich engagiert als
Gymnasiastinnen mit
73%. außerdem mangelt es deutlich mehr
HauptschülerInnen an Medienkompetenz als
Gymnasiasten im Bericht wird belegt dass
die Digitalisierung die bestehenden
Formen der sozialen Ungerechtigkeit
nicht durchbrechen kann deshalb
appelliere ich an die Bundesregierung
die engagementstrategie muss gezielt für
benachteiligte Jugendliche angepasst
werden
vor allem muss die Medienkompetenz der
Jugendlichen gestärkt werden hierfür
sind dringende Investitionen in die
digitale Infrastruktur der Schulen und
der Jugendeinrichtungen notwendig und
nicht zuletzt die die Kürzungen die wir
auch hier im Familienministerium
mitverfolgt haben
Engagement von Jugendlichen bedeutet
Mitbestimmung und trägt zu
demokratischer Bildung bei die
Digitalisierung muss hier als eine
Chance begriffen werden um die
demokratische Teilhabe für alle
Jugendlichen zu ermöglichen vielen Dank
[Applaus]
aus der Linksfraktion spricht unter
anderem die Hilfe für Flüchtlinge aus
der Ukraine an die viel von Freiwilligen
und Ehrenamtlern geleistet wurde auch
die Tafeln muss man in diesem
Zusammenhang noch mal erwähnen muss eine
sehr stark gestiegene Nachfrage gegeben
hat in den vergangenen Monaten und
entsprechenden Personalbedarf Emilia
fester für Fraktion Bündnis 90 die
Grünen Veränderung des Ehrenamts während
der corona-pandemie und auch von neuen
Formen von Engagement zum Beispiel in
der klimagerechtigkeitsbewegung was er
aber noch nicht verrät und auch nicht
verraten kann ist inwiefern sich
Engagement seit dem Kriegsbeginn erneut
verändert hat denn
Engagement entwickelt sich stetig fort
wenn die Welt sich verändert dann
verändert sich auch das Engagement und
das geht aber auch umgekehrt wenn das
Engagement sich verändert dann verändert
sich die Welt und das wohl aktuellste
und gewaltigste Beispiel dafür ist die
Revolution der mutigen Frauen und Männer
in Iran natürlich können wir uns nicht
mit vergleichen und doch steckt im Kern
genau das drin was alles Engagement
gemeinsam hat Engagement das ist das
wofür unser Herz abseits des lohnjobs
oder der Familie schlägt das ist das
Einsetzen für etwas was uns in dieser
Gesellschaft etwas bedeutet ob es der
eigene Sportverein ist in dem wir
zusammenkommen die Freiwillige Feuerwehr
oder das seenotrettungsschiff um unsere
Mitmenschen zu helfen der demokratische
protestszug für das eigene Recht auf
Zukunft ob auf der kinderkrankenstation
im Altersheim in Sprachkursen in der
Schülervertretung bei der Tafel in
Museen im Netz die Orte für Engagement
sind zahllos vielfältig und so
unterschiedlich und doch haben
engagierte eben alle eins Gemeinden sie
stützen unser Zusammenleben wollen im
Kleinen wie großen etwas Gutes beitragen
doch an dieser Stelle von mir noch
einmal herzlichen Dank dafür
das Schöne ist dass Engagement nicht nur
der Gesellschaft etwas gibt sondern auch
denen die es ausführen sich einzusetzen
und stark zu machen ist gerade für die
vielen jungen Menschen die sich
engagieren eine riesiger Teil ihres
Wachstumsprozesses es sensibilisiert für
gesellschaftliche Herausforderungen
stärkt die Selbstverantwortung zeigt
ihnen dass sie wirksam sein und etwas
verändern können
maßgeblich dafür ist aber ihre
intrinsische Motivation und deswegen ist
es mir wichtig dass sie jetzt auch noch
einmal betonen zu betonen ein soziales
Pflichtjahr wird junge Menschen nicht
langfristig zu engagierten Demokratien
machen es wird unsere Gesellschaft nicht
in ihrem Zusammenhalt stärken und auch
den Fachkräftemangel der nach 16 Jahren
Misswirtschaft entstanden ist kann ein
Deutschland ja liebe Union nicht Kitten
verpflichtete und unausgebetete junge
Menschen sind nämlich keine Fachkräfte
das ganze ist übrigens auch noch irre
teuer und dazu wahrscheinlich
verfassungswidrig was sie hier versuchen
immer wieder nichts anderes als über den
Kopf junger Menschen hinwegzuentscheiden
und das nennt man und da habe ich noch
mein neues Passwort für ihr
road-vokabelheft adultismus
jetzt Ampel gehen das zum Glück ein
bisschen anders an gegen den
Fachkräftemangel gehen wir in die
Offensive junge Menschen unterstützen
wir mit der Weiterentwicklung von
freiwilligen Dienst und anderen
Beteiligungsformen für den Bereichen der
engagement-politik erarbeiten wir Hand
in Hand mit der Zivilgesellschaft
Verbänden Wissenschaft und Wirtschaft
die neue engagementstrategie des Bundes
wir wollen neue Form von Engagement
absichern klare Kante gegen Demokratie
Feinde zeigen und für krisefestigkeit
sorgen wenn wir finden wir tun nicht
Staat sehr gut daran die engagierten in
ihrer Freiwilligkeit zu unterstützen
war das aus der Fraktion Bündnis 90
gegrünen bis vor kurzem die jüngste
Abgeordnete hier im Deutschen Bundestag
seit dieser Woche ist sie das nicht mehr
denn Emily Franz ist nachgerückt für
Heiko Maas den früheren
Bundesaußenminister der sein man da
zurückgegeben hat und die ist jetzt mit
21 Jahren die jüngste hier im Parlament
das hier ist Petra Nicolaisen die hat
heute schon mal gesprochen und kommt aus
der Union Fraktion
und auf einen Aspekt einzugehen der mir
sehr am Herzen liegt und zwar ist das
das Engagement in strukturschwachen und
im ländlichen Raum sowie in kleineren
Gemeinden in laut dem dritten
engagementbericht profitieren junge
Leute in kleineren Gemeinden besonders
natürlich von digitalen Engagement
Angeboten digitales Engagement ist
nämlich unabhängig von lang Anfahrts
wegen von engen Zeitfenstern von engen
Themen und
organisationsvorhaben und einem meist
kleineren lokalen Angebot an
Möglichkeiten um sich überhaupt zu
engagieren
auch deshalb nimmt die Bedeutung
digitale Angebote zu davon profitiert
wiederum auch das Engagement und das ist
auch eine Erkenntnis des Berichts
digitales Engagement ersetzt nicht
klassische Organisationsformen im
Gegenteil digitales und nicht digitales
Engagement ergänzen sich denn wo es
vielfältige regionale Angebote gibt
werden diese auch von Digital
engagierten genutzt das Engagement
profitiert auch weil Digitalisierung
selbst zum Thema wird wenn
beispielsweise Jugendliche digitale
Lösungen für Impftermine zum Beispiel
entwickeln um Digitalisierung mit Blick
auf kleinere Organisationen zu stärken
braucht es aber nicht nur Geld für
Ausstattung und Software im
IT-Bereich es braucht zunehmend
wissenszeit Praxiserfahrung zum Beispiel
Umgang mit Plattform und Datenschutz und
die kleinen Korrekturen haben es häufig
am schwierigsten sich gehört zu
verschaffen hier müssen wir ansetzen und
die Rahmenbedingungen weiter verbessern
der dritte engagementbericht hat dazu
Vorschläge unterbreitet viele sind in
die Arbeit der Deutschen Stiftung für
Ehrenamt und Engagement schon
eingeflossen
als zentrale
anderen am
TS leistet die Stiftung seit ihrer
Gründung 2020 jedoch viel mehr mit
Informationen Beratungs-
[Musik]
bayerischen Stiftung für Ehrenamt und
Engagement hat die vergangene
Bundesregierung einen entscheidenden
Schlüssel für eine gezielte und
strukturelle Ehrenamtsförderung
geschaffen an diesem Instrument müssen
wir festhalten die Stiftung muss
dauerhaft institutionell wie auch
finanziell gestärkt werden um noch mehr
in der Breite wirken zu können ich bin
mir sicher das wird auch ein vierter
engagementbericht erkennen abschließend
möchte ich Ihnen mit auf den Weg geben
als gemeinschaftliche Aufgabe muss die
Bundesregierung bei ihren kommenden
engagementpolitischen Vorhaben der
engagementstrategie und dem Demokratie
fördergesetz den ländlichen Raum noch
viel stärker in den Blick nehmen als
bisher denn seine Bedeutung für
Engagement Ehrenamt und
Zivilgesellschaft wird weiter wachsen
herzlichen Dank und eine schöne
Weihnachtszeit
nächster Redner ist für die SPD-Fraktion
Erik von mallowski
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin werte
Kolleginnen und Kollegen liebe
Bürgerinnen und Bürger Entschuldigung
wir erleben in den letzten Jahren dass
unsere Gesellschaft weiter auseinander
trifft der Austausch die Verständigung
zwischen Jungen und Alt zwischen Stadt
und Land zwischen Arm und Reich wird
weniger wir stellen uns deshalb zurecht
die Frage welchen Kit wir für diese für
den Zusammenhalt unserer Gesellschaft
brauchen meine Hoffnung liegt auf dem
Engagement von jungen Menschen und einer
Stärkung der Zivilgesellschaft der
vorliegende dritte engagementbericht
zeigt hierfür enorme Chancen auch denn
junge Menschen wollen sich engagieren
und Team tun dies immer mehr digital und
non- Sie müssen sich ein und werden für
unsere Demokratie gewonnen
gleichzeitig liegt im immer stärker
werdenden digitalen Engagement ein
Risiko weil dies noch stärker von
Bildungshintergrund der elternabhängig
ist wir dürfen diese steigende
bildungsungleichheit der engagierenden
nicht ignorieren sondern wir müssen
reagieren
der engagementbericht gibt hierfür gute
Vorschläge wie zum Beispiel das bessere
Erlernen von digitalen Engagement in den
Schulen aus meiner Sicht kann dies aber
für die Größe des Problems nicht
ausreichen ich zitiere mit Erlaubnis der
Präsidentin den Bundespräsidenten man
bleibt gerne und oft unter sich man
umgibt sich mit Menschen die einen
ähnlichen Lebensstil pflegen ähnliche
politische und religiöse Überzeugung
haben die gleichen Kulturveranstaltungen
besuchen die gleichen Medien nutzen eine
sehr wichtige Analyse aber was ist die
richtige Antwort auf diese Entwicklung
aus meiner Sicht kann die Antwort nur
lauten
Freiwilligendienste ausbauen und massiv
stärken so haben wir es im
Koalitionsvertrag festgehalten
wir müssen ein freiwilliges Jahr
schaffen das so attraktiv ist dass jeder
und jede es machen will was brauchen wir
konkret für einen solchen
Freiwilligendienst erstens mehr
finanzielle Sicherheit aktuell besteht
die Aufwandsentschädigung eine für eine
freiwilligen sozialen Jahr teilweise bei
330 € im Monat zum Vergleich beim
freiwilligen Wehrdienst sind es 1500 €.
zweitens wir brauchen mehr Plätze im
Freiwilligen Ökologischen Jahr im
letzten Jahr gab es auf
3.258 Plätze fast 13.000 Bewerbung wir
brauchen einen Ausbau der
Platzkapazitäten sie brauchen mehr
Anerkennung es muss für
freiwilligendienstleistende Vorteile für
eine Ausbildung spätere Ausbildung und
ein Studium geben
viertens wir brauchen mehr
Tätigkeitsbereiche wir brauchen ein
freiwilliges digitales Jahr und wir
brauchen einen freiwilliges Jahr im
Handwerk fünftens
fünften zur abschließend wir brauchen
mehr Verbindlichkeit es braucht ein
Rechtsanspruch auf ein
Freiwilligendienst ich bin überzeugt
wenn die ein solchen Freiwilligendienst
schaffen dann werden wir die so dringend
notwendigen Begegnung zwischen Menschen
verschiedener Milieus ermöglichen und
werden gleichzeitig Interesse an einem
lebenslangen Engagement Weg packen
Erik von Malotki war das für die
SPD-Fraktion und ich denke man kann
sagen die meisten seiner Feststellungen
sind erstens richtig und zweitens auch
nicht neu und dann stellt sich natürlich
die Frage warum in diesem Bereich nicht
schon längst sehr viel mehr geschehen
ist es gibt ja sehr viele Kräfte hier im
Bundestag die schon mal in Amt und
Würden oder in einer Bundesregierung
waren jetzt am Pult für die FDP-Fraktion
das gilt erst recht für die jungen
Menschen die ohne Engagement denn ohne
Engagement gibt es keinen Zusammenhalt
das war immer so und das wird auch immer
so bleiben jedoch wie wir uns einbringen
unterliegt einem Wandel der Bericht über
das junge Engagement im digitalen
Zeitalter hat für uns zwei positiven
Botschaften zum einen gibt es
erfreulicherweise eine Zunahme des
Engagements insgesamt zum anderen hat
vor allem das informelle Engagement
zugenommen diese Erkenntnis ist für die
Politik folgenreich denn bei Engagement
denken wir meistens ein Verein
jedoch Digitalisierung verändert die
Zusammenarbeit als auch die Ansprüche
der engagierten die Menschen arbeiten
inzwischen häufiger ortsunabhängig eher
Projekt und themenzentriert zusammen
feststellen lässt sich bei den Jungen
eine Vorliebe für flache Hierarchien
kurze Kommunikations- und
Entscheidungswege und der Wunsch
politisch wirksam zu sein gleichzeitig
werden formelle Mitgliedschaften und
Ämter eher gemieden immer häufiger
engagieren sich nicht Mitglieder die
Niedrigschwelligkeit für Engagement ist
folglich sehr viel wichtiger geworden
auch forschen lassen muss uns
Parlamentarier junge Menschen schließen
immer häufiger die Mitgliedschaft in
einer politischen Partei aus gerade wenn
der Trend zum informellen Engagement
geht dann müssen wir uns Gedanken machen
wie wir engagierten Bürgern Teilhabe
ermöglichen hier spielt das digitale
eine immer größere Rolle die
Digitalisierung sollte einerseits für
mehr Menschen verständlicher sein denn
wir dürfen nicht vergessen dass
Engagement in der Freizeit stattfindet
und die Digitalisierung eben kein
Selbstzweck ist zweitens die digitale
Plattform werden wichtiger weil sie gute
Rahmenbedingungen schaffen können und
vieles einfacher machen und drittens der
Bürokratieabbau ist gerade auch für das
Ehrenamt wichtig getreu dem Motto
einfach machen ich freue mich auf
zukünftige Debatten wünsche Ihnen allen
ein gesegnetes Weihnachtsfest danke
für die FDP-Fraktion der Bundestag
diskutiert über den engagementberichte
der Bundesregierung es ist der
inzwischen dritte und es ist die vorige
Bundesregierung gewesen die eben noch in
Auftrag gegeben hat auch diese
ampelregierung wird ein in Auftrag geben
müssen so hat es der Bundestag vor
einigen Jahren beschlossen proje
Legislaturperiode ein Engagement
aus der SPD-Fraktion
ehrenamtliche Engagement für unsere
Gesellschaft ist und es liegt an uns
genau das zu unterstützen den Menschen
dabei die Arbeit zu erleichtern und für
die passenden Rahmenbedingungen zu
sorgen
in der Vergangenheit war es mit der
cdu/csu leider nicht möglich das
Gemeinnützigkeitsrecht ernsthaft zu
modernisieren und zeitgemäß zu gestalten
deshalb werden wir das jetzt in der
Ampelkoalition in Angriff nehmen denn
wir wollen an der Stelle etwas bewegen
wenn auch hier geht es um die
Wertschätzung dieser Arbeit und dazu
braucht es wirkliche Veränderungen die
zeitnah umgesetzt werden
[Musik]
die Gemeinnützigkeit die sorgt bei den
Organisationen dafür dass sie Steuer
Vorteile erhalten was genau gemeinnützig
ist das ist im zweck-katalog der
Abgabenordnung festgehalten dieser
Katalog der ist historisch gewachsen und
wir müssen Ihnen dringend an die heutige
Zeit anpassen nicht nur das es geht auch
um die Frage der rechtlichen
Unsicherheit für Organisationen denn
inwieweit darf denn eigentlich eine
gemeinnützige Organisation politisch
tätig werden und wie sehr wo hört das
eigentlich auf darf sie zu einer Demo
aufrufen darf sie sich politisch in den
sozialen Medien äußern oder droht sie
dann Gefahr die Gemeinnützigkeit zu
verlieren
meine Damen und Herren wir müssen
klarstellen dass ein Sportverein zu
einer Demo gegen rechts- und
Fremdenfeindlichkeit aufrufen darf ohne
dass die Gemeinnützigkeit dadurch
verloren geht
wir werden dort für klare Regeln sorgen
und auch dafür dass sie einheitlich
umgesetzt werden können denn die
Menschen sollen sich auf ihr Engagement
konzentrieren können das ist ganz
wichtig wir wollen Ihnen an dieser
Stelle das Leben leichter machen
herzlichen Dank Ihnen eine gute Zeit wir
sehen uns im neuen Jahr
das ist der SPD-Fraktion die Redezeiten
sind jetzt etwas kürzer am Ende dieser
Debatte und das war auch schon die
dritte letzte Rednerin in dieser
Aussprache zum engagementbericht der
Bundesregierung hier kommt eine Jansen
aus der Unionsfraktion ich möchte mich
heute an dieser Stelle einmal bei allen
ehrenamtlich engagierten und besonders
beim THW in meinem Wahlkreis bedanken
denn in der vergangenen Woche durfte ich
mal wieder bei einem Übungsabend dabei
sein und miterleben wie die vielen
ehrenamtlichen dort ihren Dienst tun sie
bilden sich aus sie lassen ausbilden um
für den Einsatz fit gemacht zu werden
100 Stunden Grundausbildung die ihren
aus in einer theoretischen und in einer
praktischen Prüfung finden gilt es in
der Freizeit abzuleisten und am Ende
geht es um Menschenleben und da muss
jeder Handgriff sitzen bei den
Gesprächen die ich immer wieder führe
wird eins besonders deutlich das
Herzblut mit dem sich die Menschen
einbringen sie brennen für ihre Sache
und wir können es nicht oft genug sagen
ehrenamtliches ehrenamtliches Engagement
ist unbezahlbar und unverzichtbar gerade
für uns in den ländlichen Gebieten
die Art wie sich Menschen engagieren hat
sich in den Jecken vergangenen Jahren
verändert und so sagt uns der Bericht
dass sich zwei Drittel der befragten
Jugendlichen ehrenamtlich einbringen
aber nicht mehr unbedingt in einem
Sportverein sondern vermehrt in Form von
Projekten und zur Vernetzung und dem
Austausch nutzen Sie dabei oft die
digitalen Medien
grundlegend für diese neue Form der
Beteiligung ist jedoch eine ausreichende
Medienkompetenz und hier schließe ich
mich der Berechtigten Frage der
Kommission nach der Rolle der Schulen an
die Vermittlung von Medienkompetenz ist
vor dem Hintergrund problematischer
Kommunikations- und informationskulturen
im Internet unbedingt zu stärken denn
dem Grundlagen fehlen dem bleibt
Entwicklungschancen verwehrt laut
Bericht engagiert sich die Mehrheit der
Jugendlichen aber nach wie vor im
Bereich Bewegung und Sport und nach zwei
pandemiejahren sind die Strukturen im
Vereinssport massiv ausgedünnt das
belegt auch die aktuelle
Bestandsaufnahme des
Gesundheitsministeriums das
zukunftspaket für unsere Kinder und
Jugendlichen soll dem Bewegungsmangel
entgegenwirken aber wo wenn Turnhallen
und Schwimmbäder wegen des
Sanierungsbedarf schließen müssen die
Einstellung des
investitionspaktssportstätten stützt das
Vorhaben jedenfalls nicht denn
Sportstätten sind Grundvoraussetzungen
für Bewegung
Liebe Regierungsfraktion Engagement ist
wichtig und darum werden wir ihres in
diesem Bereich auch gut im Blick
behalten vielen Dank ich wünsche Ihnen
eine gesegnete Weihnachtszeit und wir
sehen uns im nächsten Jahr an dieser
Stelle wieder
[Applaus]
Unionsfraktion der letzte Redner in der
Debatte zum Engagement Bericht der
Bundesregierung der diesmal das Thema
Digitalisierung im Mittelpunkt hatte
wird hellgelehnt sein aus der
SPD-Fraktion Sprecher der Arbeitsgruppe
Demokratie in seiner Fraktion liebe
Kolleginnen
Engagement und Ehrenamt sind Stammzellen
von Respekt und Aufmerksamkeit in
unserer Gesellschaft durch meine das
ganz buchstäblich wir haben es erlebt
bei den Fluchtbewegungen aus Syrien aus
der Ukraine wir sehen uns daran dass
ohne Engagement die Aufmerksamkeit für
den Klimawandel kein vergleichbarer
große wirkliche Aufmerksamkeit wäre wir
leben es im Einsatz gegen Rassismus
durch bürgerrechtsinitiativen oft sehr
junge digital organisierte oder wir
Erlebens bei BürgerInnen und Verein die
in Stadtteilen Heimat schenken gerade
für einsame Menschen
das ist auch der Kern übrigens des
demokratiefördergesetzes dass wir
diejenigen verstetigt und auch
längerfristig unterstützen die oft
eingefallenet oft allein gelassen gerade
für Respekt von Menschen die bedroht
sind von Verfolgung bedroht sind von den
Feinden der Demokratie unter die Arme
greifen das ist der Kern dieses
Demokratie fördergesetzes
Respekt und Anerkennung
bedeutet aber auch
wahrzunehmen dass Ehrenamt häufig nicht
inklusiv ist und wie der
engagementbericht auch zeigt auch eine
Unausgewogenheit hat in Bezug auf
Diversität im Besuch Bezug auf Inklusion
auf Menschen mit Behinderung und auch da
ist der politische Auftrag die Bedingung
zu verbessern damit Engagement wirklich
inklusiv sein kann abschließend aber
bedeutet denke ich Respekt und
Aufmerksamkeit auch eine oft unerzählte
Geschichte hier zu erzählen in diesem
Parlament sprechen wir oft von Menschen
mit
Migrationshintergrund mit nicht
Staatsangehörigkeit als Objekten unserer
Debatte über ihre Integrationsfähigkeit
ihre Einbürgerung über ihre Abschiebung
und sonstiges wir vergessen aber dabei
das seit Jahrzehnten Migranten
Selbstorganisation und jetzt auch
jüngere Initiativen oft außerhalb von
Vereinen sich tagtäglich für Respekt und
Aufmerksamkeit für Anerkennung in dieser
Gesellschaft einsetzen und diese
Leistung dieser vielen Vereine und
Initiativen auf die wir viel zu wenig
gucken die verdient besonders unseren
Respekt und unsere Aufmerksamkeit vielen
Dank
Helge Lindt war der letzte Redner in der
Debatte zum engagementbericht der
Bundesregierung möge an der einen oder
anderen Stelle etwas nachhallen oder
auch entsprechend entschieden werden um
die runden 29 Millionen Freiwilligen die
es in Deutschland gibt besser zu
unterstützen bei ihrem Tun auch wenn die
das nicht zwingen erwarten aber kommt
sicherlich eine ein oder anderen Stelle
etwas Hilfe durchaus hilfreich sein